decenas de miles de franceses en las
calles
toneladas de basura sin recoger
escenas de violencia denuncias de
brutalidad policial y alrededor de mil
personas detenidas
son imágenes que dejan semanas de
huelgas y manifestaciones contra la
reforma de las pensiones de Manuel
macron aprobadas en votación en la
asamblea nacional tras la activación del
polémico artículo 49.3 de la
constitución
un hecho que provocó dos mociones de
censura contra el gobierno que no
triunfaron pero que cuestionaron
duramente su liderazgo pese a una amplia
oposición la ley obtuvo la luz verde
definitiva del Consejo constitucional el
14 de abril en este episodio de 5
minutos les explicamos las claves de la
ley que enciende a Francia
[Música]
En qué consiste esta ley la impopular
reforma retrasa la edad de jubilación
progresivamente desde los 62 años hasta
los 64 en 2030 y aumenta también
paulatinamente el tiempo que se debe
haber cotizado para recibir una pensión
completa de los 42 años actuales hasta
los 43 años trabajados en 2027 también
afecta a las personas que empezaron a
trabajar entre los 16 y los 18 años que
pasarán de pensionarse a los 58 a tener
que hacerlo a los 60 y quienes iniciaron
su vida laboral entre los 18 y los 20
que se podían jubilar a los 60 lo
deberán hacer a los 62
qué argumentos ofrece el gobierno
francés el sistema pensional francés se
basa en el concepto de solidaridad entre
generaciones los trabajadores de hoy
pagan las pensiones de los jubilados
actuales pero macron defiende que en una
sociedad cada vez más envejecida este
sistema es insostenible y deficitario es
decir que gasta más de lo que ingresa su
gobierno justifica la decisión con el
crecimiento de la esperanza de vida si
la población vive más tiempo debe
trabajar más tiempo y argumenta que la
mayoría de países europeos tienen una
edad de jubilación más elevada como
Bélgica Italia o Países Bajos macrón
también recuerda que su programa
electoral con el que fue reelegido
incluía este proyecto de ley pero varias
encuestas de opinión muestran que entre
un 67 y un 80% de los franceses están en
desacuerdo con la reforma y las
protestas organizadas con una unidad
sindical sin precedentes han logrado
convocar una movilización récord en la
última década
sin embargo el movimiento perdió algo de
fuerza en las últimas semanas al menos
hasta la decisión del Consejo
constitucional
los manifestantes defienden primero que
el sistema de pensiones no es
deficitario el informe anual del Consejo
de orientación para las pensiones
contabilizó un excedente de 900 millones
de euros en 2021 es decir se ingresó más
de lo que se gastó y proyecto que la
misma cifra en 2022 podría haber crecido
hasta los 3.200 millones sin embargo en
los últimos 15 años ha habido más épocas
de déficit que de excedencia y el mismo
consejo augura que hasta 2032 el sistema
pensional podría deteriorarse hasta
tener un déficit de entre el 0,5 y el
0,8% del pib
para los opositores a la reforma estas
cifras justifican que alargar la edad de
jubilación responde más a una visión
política que a una necesidad económica y
que el problema podría solucionarse de
otras formas por ejemplo con más
impuestos a las grandes fortunas según
cálculos de la ong oxfam un gravamen del
2% la riqueza de los multimillonarios
franceses podría financiar el déficit
potencial del sistema de pensiones a
futuro o con menos dinero público para
otros asuntos macron anunció un
presupuesto récord para el ejército de
más de 400.000 millones que sus
opositores criticaron con dureza por
último Quienes se oponen a la reforma
critican la premisa de macron de vivir
más trabajar más a pesar de que la
esperanza de vida ha crecido no lo hace
de la misma forma para todos el 5% de la
población más pobre vive de media casi
13 años menos que el 5% de la población
más rica en los hombres y 8 años menos
en el caso de las mujeres
recordemos que este no es el primer
intento de reformar las pensiones en
Francia la edad para jubilarse se fijó
en en 1982 en 60 años y los años
necesarios de cotización en 37,5 entre
1993 y 2007 hubo cuatro intentos de
reformas tres con éxito y una fracasada
raíz de la movilización social todas en
menor o mayor medida alargaron los años
que debían ser cotizados y recortaron
algunos beneficios especiales a
profesiones específicas el cambio más
radical llegó en 2010 cuando el
conservador Nicolás sarkozí enterró la
histórica jubilación a los 60 años y la
retrasó a los 62 en aquel entonces las
huelgas masivas no lograron frenar la
nueva ley el socialista juansó along
volvió a ampliar en 2014 el número de
años cotizados necesarios y ya en 2019
durante el primer mandato de macron el
presidente impulsó una reforma de las
pensiones parecida al actual el proyecto
que finalmente quedó archi despertó el
parón más largo del sector transportes
en 50 años es por eso que para muchos
franceses y especialmente para la clase
trabajadora las últimas décadas se
perciben como una cascada de pérdida de
derechos mientras que para el gobierno
de macron y quienes lo apoyan es
ineludible aumentar la edad de
jubilación
si le sirvió el vídeo para entender el
debate alrededor de la Reforma pensional
los esperamos en otro episodio de en
cinco minutos en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]